our goal is to inject the fuel and then
get out of the way so we will help on
job descriptions we will help source
talent from our own networks we will
help interview talent we will on board
talent and then we will leave um because
our goal is for companies to be
sustainable with it it's teach a man to
fish kind of concept we don't want to be
there it's not a managed service
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with jay jubis a
senior partner at mackenzie
jay is a leader in mckinsey's technology
media and telecommunications practice
and global leader of fuel by mckenzie
which serves the startup and scale up
ecosystem he is also a leader of
mckinsey israel tech hub which provides
services to startups scale-ups and vcs
in multiple tech sectors in israel
during the last year jay didalia due to
the huge potential mckinsey has
recognized in the israeli ecosystem
jay holds a bs with highest honors and a
masters in material science from
columbia university and a phd in physics
from mit
prior to joining mckinsey he worked as a
research associate at mit lincoln
laboratory
fuel is a different type of animal i
feel it's a different type of of idea
behind you know this idea of research
consulting deep dive but but also
working with agility and with startups
across different stages and so i'm i'm
really looking forward to picking your
brain about what you're doing with fuel
as its global leader a little bit about
your journey as well
from colombia as an engineer and then
phd at mit and so um
really jay excited in these 20 minutes
to unpack a little bit about
where you are at within the art
ecosystem and so thank you very much for
being here sure so it's a pleasure to be
here mostly to talk about fuel if i need
to talk about myself as the price for
talking about fuel i'll do a little bit
of that as well
well it'll cost just a little bit just
that i can get perspective as to you
know who you are and sort of what your
passions and motivations are because
you're you've done an engineering degree
from colombia and then you transition to
a doctor in philosophy what sort of your
path been like
in your head or what what how do you
think through yourself as a personality
you know very much an unplanned
evolution of my career as with so many
people i actually believe it or not
originally applied to college to be an
english major i thought i would study
english i was very interested in the
humanities and then i got practical and
i said well engineering you know seems
like a practical way to make a living
and then at some point uh my senior year
really late in my junior year i read a
book by steven weinberg of famous nobel
laureate physics called the first three
minutes where he describes um how the
universe came into being the first three
minutes after the big bang and i was so
blown away by the um explanation
explanatory power of physics i of course
i studied some physics part of my
engineering but i hadn't quite
appreciated modern physics and just the
beauty of it the elegance of it um and
its explanatory powers its predictive
powers so i decided to do a phd in
physics and i did a phd in physics and
cosmology and then uh after that i came
to the realization that while i loved it
and
i was okay i wasn't on a path to win a
nobel prize there are many many
brilliant people and i felt that i could
probably put my instead of being an
academic in the second or third tier
institution i thought i would try
something else where i could have a
bigger difference bigger impact and
ultimately that led me to mckinsey which
i never heard of frankly
but luckily i was um
i was at mit which is really the the
first school where and mckenzie started
recruiting scientists to join so i i
went for interviews i joined in here i
am 26 years or so later
incredible now this dissonance between
diving deep and going abroad working on
on one research topic as you would do in
a phd or or or going for a nobel prize
or rather than working with a variety of
startups how does that
[Music]
one the trade-off between these two for
from your perspective
yeah you know it really depends on um
kind of your scientific orientation uh
cosmology is different than many areas
of physics and engineering in that in
order to really assess whether you have
an interesting problem to be that you
can even analyze you have to first come
up with a bit of an 80 20 answer
so that notion of doing some back of the
envelope calculations creating toy
models simplified models of reality
before you go deep is something that um
i think is innate to who i am and you
know that's probably what contributed to
my doing cosmology in the first place
and i think that's very much the same is
true in business now business often the
80 20 answer is all we can do it's it's
what's necessary to make decisions
because ultimately in business you're
not interested in the elegance of the
solution you're interested in driving to
actions that'll make a difference and
more often than not the 80 20 version
is good enough if need be we'll go
deeper but mostly our role as advisors
is to get people to act
future faster than mckenzie you know and
the mckinsey don't know
it's pretty bold statement does do as
you just enter the fuel website what are
what are you trying to convey
just simply you know when when somebody
thinks about mckinsey
and thinks about this new
organism called fuel
yeah people tend to associate mckinsey
not incorrectly with fortune 500
companies big expensive projects lots of
expertise um but mostly in a purely
advisory capacity and what we try to
make products is in fuel we're bringing
the mckinsey you know so we're bringing
a lot of that same um ip that we
understand we understand uh the
industries we understand functional
excellence and all sorts of functions
but there's also the kids you don't know
which is we've hired lots of startup
lots of entrepreneurs we've hired a lot
of startup executives we've we've come
up with models that are very different
commercially they're not nearly as
expensive it's all success based
um so we need to shock people into
recognizing that when we come
to engage the startup ecosystem we do it
in a very very different way than we do
with the largest fortune 500 companies
and they shouldn't be scared by kind of
mckinsey price tag and the kind of a
heavy footprint we do with a light
footprint very quick drive drive to
impact and leave
yeah i mean it's one of the advantages
of disadvantages of building such a
strong brand over time that people have
these immediate associations and and
and it's and it's incredible i think
from a
design standpoint of how you can break
sort of that that that understanding and
and try to reposition the branding for
for certain types of organizations when
you're looking at mckinsey for startups
and and if as you go to the early stages
where where does a company like mckinsey
fit in to a startup that is trying to
validate their idea trying to to realize
their growth to figure out what they're
trying to do
in what ways does mckinsey fit in there
right now
yes so great question thank you so we
call it fuel because the metaphor we're
trying to associate in people's minds is
we're the kind of people who will add
fuel to accelerate growth of companies
we're not the people bringing new ideas
to startups these are the entrepreneurs
who have these really big and bold ideas
and frankly we generally can't help
until a company has established the
product market fit right that's that's a
real entrepreneur who's working things
out you know in you know in the
laboratory in the customer environment
whatever it is tweaking your tweaking
there i'm making things work what we can
do is once companies have product market
fit we're i think very very qualified to
help them scale and scale more rapidly
we inject fuel and more often than not
we're not telling companies things they
don't know what we can do is just help
them get to where they know they need to
go we know they need to go and we can we
can melt mind meld with them and help
them get there faster by injecting by
injecting human capital by injecting ip
that we have uh in different domains
and so what does that process you know
tangibly look like i'm a startup founder
i reached product market fed i have an
interesting product and uh and you know
i've heard about this fuel organization
by mckenzie and then obviously i want to
run fast i'm about to raise my series a
getting prompted to series b what are
different ways in which i will be now
interacting with mckinsey or fuel
specifically to accelerate my own growth
so i'll give you a few examples i'll
draw from my own experience so we work
in fuel across all sectors of the
economy so
i myself will do a lot of work in
enterprise software but we'll do work in
fintech i do some of that as well but we
will work in biotech and we'll work in
mobility and we'll work in
sustainability pretty much every sector
has a lot of innovation taking place
in startups and we like to be part of it
in software what we typically do
is um you know a common presentation and
there's many variations on the theme the
current presentation would be uh we're a
sas company like many says come some
traction with the smb market but we
don't know how to sell to enterprise we
now want to move up market we want to
build an enterprise motion so of course
the company knows logically what it
needs to do it knows the talent and
needs to hire
and so on but that's a very long and
time consuming process so often what we
will do is we will parachute in a team
that actually has a sales methodology
that has experience selling to
enterprise and can very quickly take a
very small and skeletal sales
organization and make them efficient and
effective selling to enterprises how
they do account planning how they
communicate value propositions how they
price and package
things like that so that's one example
uh we can help them how they generate
leads how they qualify leads there's so
many steps um in in a selling process
um which again it's not necessarily
rocket science i mean it may be advanced
analytics involved but it's it's not
beyond the capability of the
organization they just don't have the
bandwidth to hire enough talent that
they may not have the capital they might
have the time it takes to recruit the
talent and we come in and can take that
off their hands working closely with
them and make them uh very effective
very quickly
so for my what i'm understanding here in
this in this specific example you're
looking at a company who's you know they
have they seem to have problems market
fed they're trying to now
fuel towards their next accelerated
growth which potentially could be for
moving from smbs to enterprises a
traditional route would be to now hire a
team of of really great sales and
marketing and strategists and now start
a long cycle of getting them on board
and hopefully they've made the right
hire to be able to strategize and create
this playbook uh but but you have these
teams of professional parachuters who
can come in and just land in your
company work for a while get to know
your company
lead
based on the hundreds or thousands of
previous case studies that they've
observed and then but and that isn't
it's not exclusive mutually exclusive
from bringing it from hiring those
people right
no not at all we will in parallel to
that help hire and recruit to put
ourselves out of work our goal is to
inject the fuel and then get out of the
way so we will help on job descriptions
we will help source talent from our own
networks we will help interview talent
we will onboard talent and then we will
leave um because our goal is for
companies to be sustainable with it it's
teach a man to fish kind of concept we
don't want to be there it's not a
managed service
i mean you know it also sounds that
it's
it makes sense to hire the person you
want for the role after you have some
idea of how you're going to sell and
what your strategy is going to be like
because that requires a very different
perhaps personality of a person so
hiring for those roles once you have
some some foundation that you may be
helping them build with fuel it just
sounds like also the hiring process
itself will probably be a little bit
healthier right
in some cases they have very little in
some cases they may have a sales manager
but they don't have anyone reporting to
them i mean organizations are varied in
terms of exactly what time and what
capabilities they have but in general
they don't have enough of what they need
they don't have enough people who who
who have run and and are trained on an
end-to-end selling process in this case
of software the same is true in in
manufacturing of if you're doing
alternative protein and you know
building a fat a fab to do um
alternative protein kind of uh
manufacturing right so it's a very
specialized skill we have people who
know how to do that kind of thing so we
can be sort of the seed team or we can
be a team that augments an existing team
to help them design it right the the
first time so that they're not learning
you know every startup is going to make
mistakes along the way our goal is to
bring our experience so that along the
way they're making as few mistakes uh as
possible
now you you made an interesting uh
distinction before that you have the
role of the founders and the
entrepreneurs which is to find the
product market fit to build the product
and to make sure that the product is
actually something that works and then
you have a bunch of these
areas within the sort of journey that
that you could utilize these team of
professionals that are being parachuted
in so if you're looking now a little bit
more broadly at the startup scene and
where founders you know in their in
their seed series a series b stages are
focusing their time
what what is the greater picture here on
on what really are the priorities for
founders today and what types of things
they could get help with even if they
don't know today that they could and
maybe should get help with them
that it's a very broad question and the
answer really does vary very much by
founder
um you know what what i find in my
experience is one of the things founders
struggle with is is organization scale
they can't do everything themselves they
can't hire everybody they can't onboard
everyone if they can embed a culture
they can't build excellence in every
function and supervise excellence at
every function and that's very hard
adjustment for them to make i mean
founders tend to be
um you know very good and like to know
everything that's going on and that's
just not a scalable model so it
typically a typical point will be at
some point of scaling when it gets too
big for a founder to really manage
everything that's going on inside a
company that's often a time when we're
brought in but that's only a subset of
companies for other companies it's
around the commercial scaling point that
i was talking about earlier charlotte
companies who haven't been through an
exit process
it's support for an exit process for
other companies it may be
a strategic relationship with a
strategic investor how do you structure
a relationship with a strategic partner
you know each founder has things that
they are most comfortable with very
comfortable with because they've done it
before because they've got people on
their team who've done it before and
things that they struggle with then you
know our goal is
we don't believe every company needs us
and certainly even the companies that
need us don't need us at all times our
goal is to be relevant to companies at
the right time when they have something
that they would like some augmentation
of human capital for
and that happens at different moments
along the life cycle of the company i
was on the phone today with the company
um very very successful company uh it's
gonna ipo hoping ipo uh capital markets
permitting in the next several months
and what they want us to do for them is
really not nothing they couldn't do
themselves but they want an analysis of
the market that they can share with
potential investors so they want to
understand they want to be able to
communicate to the marketplace in a
credible way they're in a new space it's
not well studied by the gardeners of the
world and they want to be able in a very
rigorous way to be able to explain to
investors what their market is and how
they're positioned within that market
so again that's that's another uh
classic use case as it were of
of people like us
now for the people that are
that are working within fuel the the
parachuters if you will inside the
companies what is their experience like
i mean they're moving around from
different different projects
they're building expertise but they're
not tied to one idea or one organization
what is that experience like for them so
lots of people increasingly we're
finding that our young talent really
wants to do this kind of work so
that has got a couple of implications
one is we're getting people who have
done it a couple of times want to come
to mckinsey build some skills for a
couple of years and then go back to the
startup world we have people who come to
mckinsey out of university or at a young
age and want to do this for a couple
years then go to the startup world and
there's some older people like myself
who just are in love with this journey
that entrepreneurs have and want to be
helpful so yeah we bring a and then
we've got seasoned executives who've
been serial entrepreneurs have joined us
as eirs or senior advisory roles so what
we do is try to find the best possible
fit for the given uh task at hand and
more often than not what ends up
happening is we have people specializing
in particular areas and that could be an
industry we have people who do a lot of
software commercialization with people
who do biotech we have people who do
um
you know payments so we people either
specialize in sort of an industry so
they really understand
kind of hp space that a startup is in
and then we have people who are more
horizontal people who understand you
know how to develop a culture as a
company grows or sustain a culture as a
company grows or fix a culture you know
as a company grows and we have people
who understand how to um scale an
organization most efficiently with
people who understand what happens when
an organization is grown too quickly and
others chaos and too many people who are
not good cultural fits how do you how do
you fix that so people tend to
specialize in particular um almost
problems or i don't see problems
opportunities or challenges that
companies have and then they end up
getting very good at that and that's
part of their personal value proposition
both to other startups and when they
leave mckinsey if they leave mckinsey um
to get themselves um employed in other
another jobs
it sounds like part of the fun is then
is the dynamic nature of it which is a
obviously very much in line with what's
been happening around the world today
and and the ability for for a person to
exercise their passion for different
different ideas different technologies
different strategies but also different
types of organizations and different
stages in which they join and so it
sounds like it's very fitting for for
the times today
absolutely my wife's a doctor so i
remember she went through medical school
and in medical school you kind of rotate
through a bunch of things you know you
learn we do a little surgery a little
obstetrics little
um you know internal medicine whatever
pulmonology um so i feel like at the
beginning stages of a career tend to be
a little bit of see a lot of different
things and then specialize you can be an
internal doc maternal medicine doctor
you're gonna meet obstetrician
you know we're the same way you're gonna
be as you know someone really knows how
to commercialize software how to build a
manufacturing plant uh so it's very much
that sort of model get a broad
foundation and that's then specialized
no if i might start a founder
and and what i can see from a lot of the
founders that i work with or you know
myself and friends it's very easy to get
lost and what i can do versus what i
shouldn't do or should do and there's a
lot of moving pieces and sometimes it's
it's hard to know when it's the right
time to act and perhaps to outsource
something or get assistance what what
are some fundamental questions that i
should be asking myself as a founder
whether it's for fuel by mckinsey or
whether it's any other outsourcing
company what are questions that i should
be asking myself to wonder is this
something that i should get help with
because obviously and a lot of times if
i don't reach out then maybe a lot of
people don't know that i may need help
with this
right
it's a great question and i think at
least in my experience there are a few
different patterns of how that happens
um there's some founders you meet and
you may be in this group who have an
intuitive sense that something could be
working better right they may not have
done it before but
you know
x y and z are going great but uh you
know topic q they're struggling with and
they just have a good intuitive sense
um when things they feel things could be
going better and they just might want to
explore the answer may be you know
there's there's an element that you just
have to work things out and there's
nothing we can do to help or anyone can
do to help or there's an element or in
some cases
um you know the outsiders are able to
provide help so some of it some people
just kind of have that intuitive sense
um some people get that sense by
speaking to trusted uh confidants that
they have you know peers and that
you know they're investors uh things
like that sometimes it can be imposed by
investors or others and say you've got a
problem with acts um
you know and we like to be part of the
conversation we're not a an intensely
commercial organization we are our goal
is to be relevant and we love very much
when people reach out to us and engage
us and we can offer advice and we don't
get hired that's very fulfilling for us
too
so we we just want to be relevant and
and share our thoughts we tend to do it
in a data-driven way
so
um
you know again i'll focus on sas since
that's what i know best we have you know
a benchmarking tool we call sas radar so
we've got um very specific benchmarks
from about 250 300 private companies
plus 150 or so public companies
and we can find a relevant peer set for
any sas company you know similar acv
similar growth rate similar size and we
know what good looks like now again the
benchmark is the start of a discussion
then you've got to engage and understand
why is the number you know only average
and not top quartile why is it bottom
quartile but often when we engage we
will do it in a data-driven way but not
everyone wants to hear it that way
either so i think you kind of have to
meet founders um you know they will
learn the way they want to learn
and you know some
some wake up themselves some want to see
data some want to wait till uh investors
are beating them up um
i've seen all of those
jay thank you very much this was a
really really interesting conversation
and i loved getting to know fuel and a
little bit about yourself as well and
and yeah constantly thinking as you're
describing phil in the different ways
that you're interacting with startups
thinking to myself how i would
interact with the situation whether i
would know to ask for help and how how
such an organization can help fuel
company forward so thank you very much
this was wonderful and stay safe and
stay healthy
youtube thank you michael for inviting
me i enjoyed the conversation and
hopefully our paths will cross again
take care
[Music]
you